what up everybody it's your boy Anna Mac
here for anime out bro and welcome to
our weekly podcast called Rand cafe will
rear ant about all things animate this
week we are talking about all the crazy
anime sequels coming up in 2018 there is
a lot including a lot of major big hyped
up ones so it's gonna be quite a show
quite a show looking forward to
discussing this with my boys we got
anime recon the harem King what up but
do you have a shirt like this harem King
I don't think so no I don't I don't need
one of course you don't because you suck
next knock knocks Taku what's up my
friend yo nothing much glad to be here
get to talk about all these awesome
anime coming 2018 yeah cuz you're such
shown in trash that you like to talk
about these that my friend is called a
preemptive strike uh old you I told you
was listening
don't say anything he wasn't listening
anyways employed knock knocks Taku his
alias is sarcastic [ __ ] just so you
know that's his rock stock was alias
that he himself came up with I'm not
insulting him he's proud of it
he loves it stands for si oh yeah yeah
and back again soul maka you weren't
here last week if I recall correctly
because of work but now you're back and
machi er than ever are you doing yeah
man I'm good it's good to be back he's
follow I bloody ages so yeah yeah I'm
definitely gonna make up for lost time
oh no a goddess here yeah sorry for the
lateness gentlemen okay you just in time
for your intro yes actually I was I
didn't know cuz naal Gaara is American
everyone so I didn't know if she was
busy with Thanksgiving but I was like if
you can join us feel free to join us but
I didn't know if she would however Happy
Thanksgiving to all the Americans out
there and Roman is saying Happy
Thanksgiving to me
thank you I live in Canada but
our Thanksgiving was like in October
however still happy Thanksgiving to
Americans and now ah what's up hello
sorry for the lateness sorry no problem
no problem
and yes so everyone's link in the
description guys if you want to check
out these lovely people
and yes so I'm looking forward to this
by the way for those of you who have
been asking for months
about anime up or merch we do have now a
link in the description to the merge so
you can check that out and support a
channel that way um okay everyone can
hear me okay is this is a lagging great
now everything's gone okay cuz my
computer's freaking out a bit
it's okay it's okay guys which sequel
should we talk about first because we
have we have attack attack in season 3
confirmed for July 2018 my hero academia
season you sharted trash you the only
one that did it bud April 20 18 / Lord
season 2 January 2018 seven deadly sins
season 2 January 2018 highschool DxD
some time apparently sword art online
sometime early recon would know better
than me what a she season 2 yeah
alright captor sakura fate extra there's
also word as does the basilisk
continuation is coming in January that
I'm really looking forward to yeah no
one ever heard of that so oh well what
what everyone must know best risk
everyone to the death come on a fight to
the death
is quite satiny spool is zombie Jaeger
is freaking out he's like man we won't
be able to watch any of these sequels
cause of net neutrality our enemy from
us good it's something to worry about
but we're definitely winning Netflix I
still you
can we be honest online are not gonna
watch it thing is if Netflix actually
gets it then we're gonna have to rely on
fansubs which they could suck so badly
no they're all fine give me a break
was this patent is better than the
Google Translate dubs yeah by the way
not only not only do we have a whole
bunch of really hyped equals confirmed
for 2018 but there's also some maybes
including the Code Geass sequel which
for over a year thinking about it needs
to be it's supposed to be coming
sometime but there's no release date so
theoretically it could happen in 2018
who knows when while I wait for a bunch
of movies first oh yeah I think you'll
come June July the third movie will air
in May in May yeah
so first half of next year the movies
will be done so we still might get at
the back end of 2018 something I don't
know likely doesn't summertime's
unlikely in July I think it will come
June July they done the same thing with
was it a magician bright yeah under
special the OVA is like leading up to it
and then when the last one finished
which was September then movies yeah no
but it was leading up to the series
that's the whole point that's what these
mean movies are they're recaps leading
up to the new series look I don't know
don't know what to say
all in all I'm not I wouldn't be upset
if they canceled the whole third gear
season three
you know what I'm really excited for is
fully cool yes all have a gun forgot
there's no date for fully cool e29
tennis season three that's they did tell
us that much so unless they push it back
no they these things you know attack on
titan season two was announced for 2015
and 2016 and 2017 yeah not a cynical
negative bastard okay it's true that
they do push stuff back so obviously
here on the channel we will keep you
posted if there's some big changes but
my whole point is that we have
unconfirmed sequels supposedly in the
making including code geass season three
and one punch man season two which again
we've had a lot of news about it it was
its introductions and it was switching
studios there's no release date but
theoretically and might happen sometime
in 2018 I don't know fooly cooly as now
I mentioned huge hugely excited for that
guys violet ever gone for a second and a
third season you know am I the only one
here excited for violet ever garden no
of course yeah not a sequel that's not a
sequel retail 2018 recon next season of
fairytale by the way everyone needs to
watch the fairytale movie before
watching that the next one so no no no
no they don't the new season movie
dragon choir has it's like saying okay
you need to watch the one piece gold
movie before watching this you know you
don't know you
ya know none of these shown in movies
have anything to do with this area's
none of them they're all filler based
cash brands slide the Dragon Ball Z
movies as well why is it every time
anyone brings up Fairy Tail turns into a
pointless argument
yeah yeah there's two series I'm looking
forward to in the spring that comes like
same time as aqua no hero and that is
the Full Metal Panic
for which looks interesting I don't know
if you're familiar with that serious but
I thought the original formula panic was
a bit overrated to be honest I don't
think it's over eight I mean I never had
anyone going crazy over it but it would
still really everyone loves it I mean
Arcada
like sings its praises oh yeah I don't
know anyone doing that but yeah the
other series of looking forward to as
well is official North Star Series could
so Ted nor can we Genesis yes manga date
back to the 80s yeah it's good it's a
sequel to Fist of the North Star
yes fun years old when it came up 83 no
way Wow oh my remove what's happening
here okay so so some really interesting
stuff going on by the way in-laws isn't
echad he said happy holidays Happy
Holidays to you law's old an amazing
travel what's up my man all day I've
been busy lately but he's he's here
hanging out a cross is here let's all
talk to him on discord by the way are we
gonna soul are we gonna have an
after-party in this Court boys chat show
yeah yeah if you guys are free yeah I'm
definitely up for yeah so guys after
anchor faith you want to have a voice
chat after party in our discourse or a
link in the description be hang out
there for a bit it's up to you
that's cause you suck you suck oh my god
free is getting a third season yes
indeed yeah oh my god I'm not looking
forward to it because it's not my type
of show there's a third season of fully
cooley for 2018 this is confusing my
anime list what are you doing yeah well
we're getting Tokyo ghoul be eventually
which no one has any idea if it's gonna
be total crap
if it's gonna be following the manga
that's one that's gonna be good never
second season two drifters coming as
well as ma Jean index whatever three oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're talking yeah
one America's trying to ask a question
sure there's a Kings avatar as well
season two that's not an animate cuz
it's Chinese bro it's still an anime
wait were you were you asking about
fully Chloe no yes so fully cool I
believe season 3 will come out on the
night in 2019 and season 2 in 2018
they're both scheduled for 2018 mistake
on the website because I remember what I
when I read the news it said one year
would be these into one year would be
season 3 but I think we will see not
license access right [ __ ] like that
hot like stuff happens stuff changes
constantly in the anime industry so we
do have to pace ourselves or that well
yeah it is actually there is to sort out
on lines coming out Alec ization an
alternative gun Gale online Oh
one's an original story shoot me now
I don't know how the alternative gun
Gale online is gonna be cuz it's it's
none of the characters I know are there
not even Austen or not even care to its
brand new characters which is amazing
which sucks ass bro honestly you should
be a journey from like a client's
perspective or something adding new
characters I mean come on
ok I so don't understand you what
characters are you afraid are gonna get
overshadowed no I'm just sometimes
afraid kirio not silicum might not get
to change no no you don't understand
it's just that I'm afraid that they
might be you know maybe myself or more
over power than Kirito basically like
they're they like they don't kind of a
cute anymore then you assign and just
making someone even more overpowered
than let's let's do some psychology here
guys why is anime recon so personally
connected to cuticle
that he considers that a personal insult
if anyone insults
Kirito for this that self-insert in us
what is this that self-insert in when
you see something sees the character
he's like yes yes I want to be like cute
oh yes you know and then like when he's
alone at home he puts on like he's
scruffy old black jacket plastic jelly's
hair back you know starts walking around
with the broomstick can like ha special
attack does he need to boom sticks even
though they're not managing ones plastic
ones wouldn't but you know Corey he
doesn't have to deal with it ooh what
I'm mostly excited for also gracia
Phantom are you changing the subject
Rika did anyone watch that Jin no
guardian because I started out I tried
it too much but there's a second season
coming that are terrible one room is
getting a second season I think I know
one Mike now that the kocchi kocchi
kocchi yeah what is getting worse on
phantom trigger look Tolkien lambu seems
to be having some kind of wait why do
you like the main character of grass aya
any less than Kirito it's literally the
same exact character okay there's a
difference between no and get Ito
there's a difference between you know I
would say the guy the guy the guy
ingress aya is more like the main guy
who's in Full Metal Panic no he's not is
an obtuse character who doesn't know
anything about society or normal life
because he has basically raised to be
some sort of super assassin fedosya
mercenary guy this other
is just like so edgy badass he gets a
harem of lollies to follow him around
everywhere while he knows we not talk
about harem of lollies please think you
know moving on the discussion harem and
the Chad said he liked the livestream
thank you hurry everyone if you enjoy
rank of Fame be sure to leave a like it
lets us know and caster for life we
usually just puts [ __ ] posting comments
actually made some serious comments
saying that he really hopes that code
geass season 3 will be coming in 2018 in
the fall because that would be the
10-year anniversary since ended that
would be interesting he also mentioned
that steins gate 0 is also scheduled for
2018 as well so it's another huge sequel
I also thought of that earlier so yeah
guys 2018 will be a crazy year so I
think hasta for life is ups and for
Gurren Lagann season 2 but have seen
some homes are made alive season 3 oh
neko para yay anything that
hello guys date alive 3rd season kicks
off are you kidding me I really kind of
liked it a little bit retour needs to go
to [ __ ] dependency its happy that so
some of my favorite hackers are getting
a sequel no Hara my photos just all
girls are the frames that makes Erik toy
as a boy and surrounded by girls yeah
shocker Rika or the harem King 2018 is
gonna be a good year yes because dxd is
coming out of course darling you're
Frank's going to be the season anything
studio trigger I always give it all I
want to give it a good chance screw to
studio trigger
never been impressed because you not
once because your crap taste in anime
Knox I already told you that your crap
taste
stop using triggers bad then I might
agree with him no no I like trigger hey
trigger mm-hmm I'm triggered trigger
that's some really good anime like his
neighbor was crap no keys neither and
kill the kill with the only series that
they did that I liked I didn't really
like Inferno cop as much as it was
humorous and then one I really didn't
like was that was it ninja Slayer Jesus
Christ I wasn't expecting it to be a
clone of like like the whole premise the
story and everything I mean I felt sorry
for the Western like the amount has the
road and is that it was pretty much
animated on PowerPoint it was no it took
it took no think about this it's like
these American girls for yeah okay we
wanna you know make our mark in the
manga industry we really like it
we respect it you know put this awesome
manga together and the manga does look
good trust me you should check it out it
really looks good then you get that
anime and you got these like cutout
figures just like being across the
screen bouncing up and down and stuff
and then say like still frame with a
shaky camera and yeah yeah and that's it
and it's like no and throw them around
the screen as well the fire they fold
the whole like code gears came and and
produce season free like that series
like you guys are just you guys have
planned so you don't get how
revolutionary that was man anyway so
what rating didn't get on my anime list
I'm pretty sure it's low like for
probably probably a free is
for the Christmas in 500 years I was
gonna be considered a modern six point
six one six
who gave me a five six point six really
0.1 and recons give it to me to watch
evil or live with like a 4.7 just layer
from animation six points Wow wait is
that even the right one then just layer
from animation yeah that's the right one
that's the right one yeah yeah they need
to put from animation in the title
because otherwise you'd watch it you
wouldn't know if it was animated thanks
gay guys they were steins gate zero what
is this oh that's the alternative
storyline basically where I think yeah
but that thing got sounds around they
don't know if it's gonna be a bit
imagine oh say a no na I won't say who
just in case you know people interesting
singing reducers but she the one the
miss dr. pepper
you know she dies instead instead of
being saved and then it's yes the
messages they're getting from her
reaction to so yeah yeah it might be a
bit more psychological than the others
yeah I mean depending where they want to
take it well yeah Lupin the third is
getting a part for yeah new yo uh mushi
pedo as well you guys are I feel like I
just reading off my anime list or
something right yeah just like you man
I'm not I'm not really looking at the
chat um says he or she would like to
talk about the seven deadly sins season
two and yes that's coming in like a
month
people in trash shut up
not to say anything
yeah no recon week on you have no
grounds insane this coming season we're
gonna meet the final sin we're gonna
meet some crazy new bad guys that put
the other ones from season one to shame
it's going to be an absolutely insane
day I can't wait to see some of the
stuff animator from the manga I can't
wait to see bond and malleolus in action
oh it's gonna be it's gonna be it's my
biggest thing that I'm waiting for for
winter 2018 for sure
along with gonna be one of the fam enemy
yeah so um yeah I'm really looking
forward to seven deadly sins because I
have yet to really see an adventure
Shonen with overpowered characters that
I actually liked that's pretty much the
only one in the roster well which ones
are seven deadly sins can you think of
any other like shown in with Opie
characters that you like no I don't know
in fact no is it close as a shounen mm
you know what a hooker my heart's crap
I like oh my god you know but I liked it
more so because I've read the novel's
but yeah oh that very well could be but
I thought you tied my hooker Coco no
debt to say yeah yeah Shonen no it's not
whatever it is that guy okay he's
sitting in his freakin basement with a
gun he pulls the trigger and a fleet of
ships that are coming from another
country is that great it's a cat killer
right motionless characters motionless
characters who gives no [ __ ] Oh as
winter 2018 I think the thing I'm most
excited for is a psyche second season I
don't even know what that is
psyche yeah it's a comedy hilarious
yeah Oh for those in the chat thinking
one punch man is a overpowered Shonen No
it's not it's the same in just so you
know it's a parody of Shonen with the
sentence you write up with the Opie
stuff and yet they somehow managed to
make an interesting because again it's a
light-hearted troll Ron they have some
serious stuff but it's more like usual
heavy dose of humor throughout which i
think is again kind of what makes it
bearable like they're not taking himself
so seriously like Castlevania anyways
the point is hey Castlevania was good
Castlevania was terrible terribly
animated terribly done just there no it
wasn't that one's all that they will go
forever because there was literally
people on both sides of the field a
Humana Marek
it was not terribly done and it was not
terribly anime games if you play the
games you understand it was from its
base from the games okay not history is
based on my love if you played the games
you'd understand if you read the books
you'd understand if you'd read the manga
you'd understand is the anime good or
not ones I know you're in the chat one
piece anime right now is like the worst
thing ever
okay manga is great anime is terrible
that's just fact of life true the an
ablation should stand on its own and if
it doesn't then we have to call it off
for it but in terms of you have seven
deadly sins one thing that's interesting
about season two is that they're gonna
introduce villains that are also Opie as
[ __ ] it's gonna be crazy so it's gonna
be Opie protagonists versus a lot of
Opie villains so it's gonna be just like
a clash of titans it's gonna be ethical
as I say hashtag epic oh epical it's a
new no III queues that multiple times
now bongo stray dogs yes yes getting and
it's getting another season yo no way it
is yes it is shut up I'm not lying it is
getting my season I like that a lot
that was a great super parent when when
when is that come in then 2018 no
release date yet oh so it might not be
but well I'm excited cuz I really like
bungo Street like I thought it was a
tear above my hair I could a Mia first
superpower anime
oh yeah there's Tokyo ghoul we all but
us that is a continuation I guess I
don't
disease I don't wanna continue though
because I mean for those who have read
google manga and seeing like the first
season of the anime you can include lose
my bad
a new anime crossover with Tokyo ghoul
Tokyo ghoul but Kenickie has a harem of
lollies yeah no no no but no but the
thing is the issue I'm having is where
Tokyo ghoul we should star the problem
is the Tokyo ghoul anime and Tokyo ghoul
blue a anime doesn't end where that
where the first manga ended for Tokyo
ghoul we to stop so there's a chunk of
information missing yeah I mean this
couldn't wait
I didn't want to touch it with a
ten-foot pole cannibal porn is always
mentioned that Funimation license the
Code Geass movies yes so one thing with
the koteas movies is I definitely want
to make a video doing a breakdown of the
movies but there's no way for me to
actually watch the movies right now
without going to Japan to a theater
watching it raw and then trying to
figure out what the hell happens so
until you know we can actually watch the
movie with some subs I can't really make
a video on it for those of you wondering
why I haven't yet but I'm looking
forward to seeing the movies and getting
some actual real news about the sequel
because I feel like they've been jerking
us around for a year now about the
sequel and selling merch the whole time
you know from the hype so I feel like
they need to deliver some freaking news
guys okay there's some other
continuations that I think one of them
at least and
I may be interested in there is a
outcast the continuation to that I don't
know if anyone saw it with him fighting
like they're zombies and stuff we've
like you know actually fighting the
zombies like you know martial arts what
everyone stuff and then there's Nexus
Adonia third season so yeah and four is
a anime that I've seen the first two
seasons and it's it's an interesting
kind of philosophical action space mecha
anime so yeah I definitely like I don't
like the animation is 3d but I you know
I still enjoy UNM overall however I
don't I definitely don't like animations
yeah yeah but it's still not as bad as
Arjun which I gene yeah I didn't was the
worst
that was actually my sergeant I don't
how can you like no I didn't like the
animation like but it was enough to like
where I could deal with it you know what
I mean like I don't imagine a lot of
people that watch Ruby like the
animation they just like the story
no a lot of people like the animation in
Ruby ajan I didn't like it because I
mean I could look past the animation
just because the black ghost things were
animated really cool yeah those were I
just thought every character was like
the blandest possible character ever I
mean you have a bad guy that's bad just
because he's bad and the good guys good
because like whatever why not no there's
a reason why they're bad and good
they even explode widely in anime
everyone's racist against da jeans
because they're immortal that's
basically what it is though I mean I
know I just
anime for you yeah nobody's understand
the boodle
you know I mean people will hate on
Sony's got you more to it especially
when they probably are getting like that
and I say they were yeah I didn't see
the second season but like in the first
season you can already tell that they
were leading up to something really
really big well to me Arjun I didn't
like it for the same reason as NOx
mentioned none of the characters were
relatable or interesting to me and
definitely in terms of like the only
person that I kind of liked was the
theme
cop girl who was also an object when
color they're not relatable to you but
no because really I okay so the main guy
is a sociopath and you just got like I'm
a sociopath and now this [ __ ] is
happening to me oh that's weird
his sister what happened but okay truck
was his friend and then the other guy
were supposed to kill everyone and then
the cops all right we're gonna kill
these Audion but they're like school kid
- all of a sudden come up with all of
these crazy powers but realize does it
be necessary
I don't know why people don't like CG I
mean pretty sure there's a lot of money
put into it to make it a 3d animated
scenes in Kung Fu Panda were amazing I
loved it good stuff yes thoroughly I
mean I was preferred to keep 2d alive
because I liked the style
however it's not necessarily that is
just that it's 3d that's why I think
it's bad by the way let me know guys in
the chat if anyone there like Arjun and
why because yeah I definitely wasn't a
big fan but in terms of like Arjun and
Castlevania like it wasn't 3d but like
one thing that in both those shows is so
jarring is how their facial expressions
are completely unnatural why do make
them what you made a mistake you said
their facial expressions in plural they
don't have plural facial expressions
that's one facial expression they try to
make their face is kind of like follow
human motions but it just feels fake and
it failed like it feels awkward when
their faces move and it was very jarring
to me so I don't know if it's like the
animation just isn't there yet the 3d
that they're trying but that definitely
did not work and with with Castlevania
yes they had no facial expressions what
a joke speaking of see what watching
berserk and the always is getting a
movie not a sequel yeah I know I did
tell the chat that's
Oh anyways speaking of CG when watching
berserk season two at the very end of
the episode of the very last episode
they showed 2d animation of berserk
that was mind-blowing by how amazing it
was
I like it when they do something like
erased you guys have watched today and
they have smaller and they did show 2d
animation yeah when they balance like 3d
usage with 2d then yeah it looks okay it
looks good when basically CG that's fine
there's no problem like the best example
you can see really is Gundam origin
Gundam origin Judy Barr on like near
enough 3d models and especially when the
Maximian use yummy but it's a lot more
balanced than what a keto look like that
would a ketone when he then switched to
the like the max in it it looked
completely different
yeah I mean it stood out you could see
the difference whereas with Gundam
origin the two because they're
constantly using CJ CG alongside with
the 2d even when light is just day to
day characters it blends very nicely
yeah I mean you don't it doesn't really
jump out at you how different it is
personally I didn't mind hakito like I
don't mind if they're like CG
backgrounds and stuff like that because
that's expensive to make in 2d but the
core should still be 2d when they go
full CG that's where I feel like there's
an issue but now you were gonna say
something and before you do we add the Z
boy mm a chat saying now I got a best
girl I don't know if the boy means here
in the stream but go ahead now well I
was going to ask you guys on what the
seat for the ones that don't like the
CGI if it was more realistic and if it
did have more realistic facial
expressions do you feel that would kind
of be like the weird kind of realistic
robot effect like do you think that
freaked you out a little bit
look the the animation in Disney movies
like Zootopia or whatever
was really good I mean let's be honest
Japan can't do cg yet to that extent
well has a lot of good thank you
yeah Final Fantasies an example of
that's very good animation not yeah but
still again you look at their faces and
when they move their mouths it's like
what the hell is happening yeah there's
a grieving face and they're whispering
face are exactly the same it's different
because they're trying to turn anime
into CGI but they're also probably
trying to avoid too much of the
realistic facial expressions I think
because there's a lot of people out
there who get really freaked out when
cartoon characters or CGI or human or
robots are too human or lifelike like it
freaks a lot of people out well like
Harlock hot without Harlow Captain
Harlock that thing that was amazingly
animated which version the movie the CG
movie yeah they're experimenting with
children of the whales is CG okay you I
didn't even notice it was CG for the
first few episodes was it CG yeah
paint it over nicely yeah because it was
actually misty connection that told us
oh yeah oh there's a good CG animation
it's with the well the girls made of
crystals I don't know if I don't know
what the name was
the cute genderless girls and it's so
good I'm not gonna lie the CG is amazing
plus the grass effect aw so I guess this
is all just wasn't an option think
whatever production studio has enough
resources and artists and money and
stuff like that to produce something
that actually is really eye-catching to
me to make something like that yes so
much money so much [ __ ] money but
they did very well what I'm impressed
you guys aren't gonna be watching
you will give your chance I'll give it a
chance depending what that CG looks like
because obviously like there's like a
fancy Cannes glaive that CG is awesome
dancer oh that CG is awesome if it's on
that level I'll watch it on the same
level was like Ruby or berserk or some
[ __ ] like that I ain't watching it is it
gonna be like a dream level it's gonna
be like a level it's only I was talking
about Godzilla the new one yes
keep up recon keep up bro I didn't I
didn't hear you say about the budget I
guess the day porn it I mean obviously
if they're if they're just doing a movie
then it chances are to see he's gonna
look bad yeah like I like how you had
the free movies of berserk they use the
CG with it the first one does look kind
of rough in places and it progressively
gets better like there are some rough
parts in the second movie as well
especially when it comes to the hundred
man battle thing like before he starts
fighting it looks a bit yeah I mean and
then after you starts firing you know it
starts looking a bit bad and then the
last one is like damn near perfect yeah
I mean so here watch berserk except for
us okay
yeah I mean when you have like a series
like Arjun will be nice to sit on yeah
yeah I mean many of us okay you know you
have the problem of like Overlord has a
lot of CG and it uses its CG very nicely
no yeah yeah but I mean that's balance
those in like the death knight or
whatever bounce so that's okay but I'm
talking about pure CG so like something
like no no no was it
aku no Hanna did you did you see that -
no Hanna where the one would really
realistic looking like characters they
have like dark outlines to look like
they're drawn but it's I mean from 3d
and that looked kind of horrible and
well that looked very horrible yeah that
that wasn't really CG as much as it was
rotoscope animation I think Final
Fantasy was a
good example of some amazing seat like
CGI like that they did a good job on
they spent a lot of work on well that
was my example so thank you know who
here has played yeah yeah I am follow
them near enough I mean for me and I
never bothered refining 2 & 3 but all
the others yeah yeah no I'd say I need
to play 15 years I was gonna be good I
mean the manga is on season 3 at the
moment so you know I'm yeah and in the
manga is already on season 3 because the
light novel is different the manga is
the same as the anime will you get an
anime you're gonna get in the manga but
in the light novel is completely
different like in the light novel our
bed elves got sisters he's got an older
sister and a younger sister but you're
never gonna see them are you never gonna
see them you told me that just now and
you never told me that
yeah no no no you know you wouldn't want
these sisters the older sister she's
mentally disturbed in the sense of she
had a baby taken from her or she lost
the baby so she's always got that kind
of like motherly instincts naturally in
it that she wants to love someone but
she's gone insane with it face her face
has no skin really long hair like Samara
from the ring or the grudge you know the
woman from the grudge yeah I mean and
yeah she's twisted she's one round with
a knife
sister yeah electric your all night baby
Caroline but yo in terms of Overlord I
have to say that albedo is one of my top
five white foods of all time so I
wouldn't say it's like Sao - I wouldn't
say psyche I say yo I mean there's very
loose comparisons where okay the guys
now in the game okay
he's now stuck in a game okay is it
there's no feeling of it like please say
you guys have seen the dot hack sign
series well I like the dot hack sign
series well first I watched a different
one not sign I watched a different one
and I started sign I got about six
episodes in and every time I was gonna
start the next episode I was really
tempted to strangle myself because of
how bad and slow it was going it's
really good
yeah a lot of people had a problem with
the pacing issues of toxin um guys
Jojo talks too much is in the childhood
sub Jojo yes encouragement of climb is
better than overlord
first of all I don't know what encourage
mental climb is but it sounds like a
soft rock band from Vancouver Canada
yeah that plays into this discussion at
all Jojo a voice sounded like someone
trying to like tell Klein to actually do
something in Sao I agree with Jojo right
climbing not Klein okay I agree with
Jojo I was gonna agree with him I was
gonna say yeah client needs to do
something but ya know I can't agree on
that because I ain't seen encouragement
of crying I still agree with Jojo okay
be a brown-nose we don't care but for
those who like max we've got to
continuations well pat
but we can call a continuation because
it had my of EA's back back in the day
like 80s 90s kind of thing and then
there's Fafnir dead aggressor the beyond
right right yeah that's that's gonna be
come on I wasn't very good it was good
fast it was good I wasn't no not that
one you think of the one where the guy
went to the school of all girls and got
opium whatever oh yeah Amex is more
focused mixer some wit guy will not know
you're talking next there's full mental
panic y'all so that's mech yeah I
already said that
alright why wait
a guy called the silver philosopher and
Chad says he didn't like Death Note like
what kind of get anime triggered by
making fun of Death Note
well like I just don't care how anyone
doesn't like death no but I can
understand it because you know after
after L dies it loses steam in it so
maybe that just disappointed him so much
maybe he enjoyed the whole L and light
you know crushes much that once they
were gone he was just like [ __ ] it hey
guys me but let's call a spade a spade
he's saying it to trigger everyone
apparently it worked on anime ik
what a loser and basically I think that
Death Note is probably one of the top 50
anime of all time for sure but actually
likes Death Note because it has very
little fanservice yeah that was
brown-nosing no total brown is he degree
kinda have you actually watched Death
Note let's be honest like half of it no
the whole anime and the whole movie both
you watched the whole death hell yeah
it was god that's wrong with you it's
before 2008 yeah probably started before
me he became
me yeah I know but I just just I just
had to watch it it was good but I
started I'm not gonna lie like it went
down a lot for me after L died yeah
that's not for the mini right the
animation sucks and I still love the
store what how do you can say that you
know I stand with him there were a lot
of parts where you can tell that the
animators were actually making it easier
on themselves but that's with a lot of
anime a lot of the ones that you think
is like amazing godly great they have
that yeah I mean it's just that kind of
business it's very difficult business I
really like I like death not overall as
a whole even off NDL thing because you
know it has to come to an end somehow we
finished drag it out for 800 episodes I
wasn't no no no I mean they could have
ended with oh no I'm upset about that
whole thing
my main issue throughout the series if I
had to pick one problem was light is
freakin stupid okay
he is the dumbest main character that
they're trying to convince you smart
ever know that's the Death Note
Netflix no that's the Death Note
madhouse no no that's just no not true
he's smart but he's not perfect but he's
still smart okay
which idiot go through the whole death
no right but by the fact that L is got
so close to him so fast and he has a
completely untraceable godly weapon he
can't be that smart okay I'm just gonna
say that that movie was better than the
enemy no no but I mean that's you say
now okay so Kira's not small because oh
oh come on I don't like what was
bothering me is that they were
portraying him to be equally smart 2l
when really he wasn't even close
well you can see superpowers that L is
even smarter
but L is not necessarily as
Machiavellian as light so why that bat
is not intelligence my friend yes but
doesn't matter because light wins by
playing dirty but in life that happens
people win by playing all right
I like death note I'm not saying I don't
like death note I'm just saying he was
dumb for most of seasons the thing
having for the first 10 episodes he was
just an idiot I mean he he starts
killing people on a student schedule so
then they're like holy cow maybe it's a
student and there's like oh man they
figured out it's a student cuz I hacked
into my father's computer so now I'm
gonna start killing him on the hour and
they're like wait a second that means he
must be acted be able to access police
information well duh you know but not if
it was viewing if it was you and you
were 17 I bet you would make mistakes
like that too
who's me and I was 17 yeah you know the
world would be a much better place right
now diverting himself afterwards even
though that he made all of the white
he's telling me look light wasn't a
stupid he was like crazy grade point
average and his IQ was really really
high too and his dad was like a part of
the freakin chief of officer so he had
the access to do what other people
couldn't yeah but if he wouldn't have
looked at that access if he would have
just ignored it then L wouldn't realize
how maybe he's accessing police
information but he's trying to do the
right thing like when he first got the
death note and how he was first thinking
and there's my perception of marking
down people and doing stuff like that
like he is 17 so yeah he is going to
stumble in some of his mistakes he is a
kid but his IQ is crazy
most 17 year-olds wouldn't been able to
devise what he did I wouldn't say I
wouldn't say it was a noble goal like it
might have sounded like a noble goal
what he said he was gonna do but by
Episode six he was killing loads of
innocent people is it sex cause he wrote
down Naomi miss Ora in Episode six which
is in Episode two when he wrote down ill
Lind L tailor he was
basically saying I am now evil bastard
it's also showing you though how power
corrupts you know what I mean like he
did you know because I agreed power
corrupts that's amazing but that's not
what I'm coming from that's not my angle
here anyway the reason that death knell
couldn't end at the L my killing L is
because death no the story is a Greek
tragedy where the main character will
allows his hubris to be his downfall in
the end so what mother's basement said
that's not as hubris yeah but mothers
basements wrong have a basement
so we're table all the channel mother's
basement the anime channel okay sounds
like a widow he is he is a public out
some [ __ ]
what other what other sequels do we need
to touch on like in terms of both attack
of time in my here academia it's it's
just gonna be crazy like I can't wait to
see these next arcs your animated or
both obviously read the manga for both
and it's just like I'm telling you mine
here Kamiya season 3 is gonna be way
better than the first two because the
first two have a lot of slow parts and
like training parts and like exam like
that's the stuff I'm into i like the
villain arcs the most and season 3 is
going to be all villain arcs it's gonna
be freakin awesome so I came for that
and attack on Titan I just love
everything about attack on Titan so it
does just gonna be amazing
no loss for DX oh I can tight and then
my hero academia are overrated
but that's just me how can you possibly
what are you talking about what are you
saying that you said it's amazing I
don't think it's amazing then what do
you think is amazing what is amazing
well there are a lot of things that are
amazing come from the toilet eaters on
that's amazing
me attack on Titan is on the same level
as Code Geass in terms of just
entertainment and action and okay so
there we go we disagree fine I don't
mind disagreeing III don't think attack
on Titan was that good I don't think it
was bad but I don't think it was that my
favorite anime man like and and manga -
you're alive you know what you know you
know it's worth it away from you Naruto
the shittiest anime
well okay I don't think anyone was even
thinking of Naruto like we're just
trying to figure out what the hell NOx
finds a decaying accent oh I think I'm
pretty sure it looks fine shonan's just
shonan's that I think are better than a
tagging Titan um
Fairy Tail Hunter hunter by miles head
like no compares every tail not Fairy
Tail I mean the first arc of Hunter
hunter and in no way did a drum you know
entertain me as much as anything in the
Titan Titan but you didn't watch the
best arc or the second best arc or even
the third best art I haven Hunter hunter
that I'm open-minded wonderful no a
triad like being the greatest anime
the first episode of attack Titan was
one of the best first episodes I've ever
seen in anime I think the problem the
problem when hunter hunter which attack
on Titan hasn't got is hunter hunter is
very generic in the sense of the tropes
it has like it is a straight-up battle
Shonen that you'll get from you no
nooooo bleach one piece but it's but
again it is I thought it was so generic
I thought it was literally so it doesn't
matter those tropes are still there yeah
whether or not you have to look at arc
like a hundred [ __ ] chapters down the
line those tropes are still there and
that's what I'm talking about
the tropes are there so initially when
you're watching it you're gonna feel
like this is another generic part with
Shonen where's the star
we've attack on Titan there are not
those generic tropes I mean it doesn't
even feel like a battle shown in your
ride it and it isn't the battle shown in
exactly so I'm just saying it's not good
that alone that alone it feeling
different or new would then inspire more
people to then try out and get into it
rather than stick with the same generic
[ __ ] they've been watching for the last
10 years and they've got sick and tired
of okay well then if you don't want me
to what about Maggie is that generic
battle Shogun yeah yeah
Maxim is very strong generic battle
Shonan Maru you sure
I don't mind walkie but it does not
compare to that I don't think I
preferred Maggie the attack on Titan
I love Marty I like I just I just I just
want to say that recon loves Maggie none
so are you gonna admit defeat now or are
we gonna dress like most saying I don't
like attack on Titan I love attack on
Titan and moggy amasing there we go we
both lose yeah we won't lose I'm not
saying I hate attack on Titan I actually
love it
by the way recon I mean a caster for
life said that recon is better than both
mother's basement and did you bro heard
that the enemy recon is better than did
you bro and mother's basement and
definitely better than pedantic romantic
bucks yeah what is your favorite motto
all this gets recorded looks what is
your favorite Maggie my favorite Maggie
you mean out of the three or four out of
the three or four yeah which one was
your favorite one for everyone's you
none so what do you wanna pick they all
been none of them are that smell you
know my favorite was Sinbad no Balkan
Simba oh oh I thought which season I
thought you said which actual Maggie you
Mountain which character what I'm saying
like which series
oh the second season
kingdom of magic mine was the fourth sea
kingdom of magic to me is not as good as
the first season
there's Kingdom magic there's a
labyrinth form as well all good just
like how do we make it Harry Potter okay
let's do this
I like the climax at the end that climax
was amazing
Alibaba Aladdin and um last season I
don't know have you all finished meeting
abyss yes I did
Anna Mack I read the manga to be honest
no I have not finished this oh I know
and that's why I asked you specifically
because it didn't compel me to finish it
man I'm watching the first five episodes
and I was like I probably will people
say it ended up being good but I use
like I said like there's certain anime
there really like I look forward to
watching the next episode like this
season
Garo vanishing line I can't wait to
watch the next episode it's such an
interesting anime with made an abyss it
didn't really do that for me
you have to it's gonna continue man it's
gonna definitely get another scene
apparently the the manga from an abyss
is yeah it gets even better than the
anime got at the end
oh no no yeah the next season that you
get when you get that guy Lord of dawn
Jesus Christ trust me it's gonna get oh
my god it's gonna get so dark though I
need to I need to finish that fine I
will what I will say guys I will say
that black clover I caught up the black
clover and even though the first few
episodes were met I'm now actually
really enjoying it yeah there you go
[Music]
it's it's corny but it's like it's fun
they create a fun world there's a bunch
of interesting characters and it's just
tell me one character I'm gonna move
into Animax team now the leader of the
black bulls is a interesting guy he did
nothing he was shaking his whole
your existence right now Yami was
playing cards stupid bag and I also like
I also like how you know and asked I
have a rivalry where they're like rivals
but they don't like beat each other and
like [ __ ] like you know anime not to
respect each other unlike the cliche
robbery which said I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you and your family be
watching fairy tale next very tell it
was fine but I didn't feel like
continuing well it gets better I'm not
saying I would ever put it in my top
anything but it's just an anime to watch
black clothes is the story like of
nooooo set in the world of fairy tale
that's it there's one piece there's my
TV there's a bunch of stuff it borrows
100% and like I said I'm not gonna say
is the greatest anime ever but I'm just
saying that it's an entertaining
experience just like Dragon Ball super
is entertaining experience when you
watch I'm not I'm not saying that it's
like a masterpiece but it's fun to watch
ok ok ok
I used to be against you a little bit
marker to be honest I thought that you
were very you know yeah different taste
than the most I mean looks I'm pretty
sure just forcing yourself to watch
flock clover because it's gonna have I
was always my level of you're like I'm
actually happy that you know that people
can find some happiness out of it you
know yeah we're happy for that
no no no it's just happy that you know
that there's even those [ __ ] is coming
out in the anime community at least
someone can be happy with it you know
you ever hear the bike meme it's it's
been going crazy blowing up it's
basically about a kid who goes and sees
that his bike was stolen and then he
calculates himself whoever stole my bike
is probably happier
Groo had more happiness points then I
have sadness points that it's missing so
the total average happiness in the world
went up so it was good that it was
stolen I don't think that's a meme man I
think that's a parable or something no
no it's that that's how it started and
then it became this crazy meme and
everyone's making fun of it okay so it's
a meme now cuz to me just sounded like a
wife or something oh it's garbage but in
terms of the other thing that's awesome
about black clover the mini clover thing
is totally stupid and those shouldn't be
there the hell's lines
what's a mini Chloe thing the thing at
the end of each episode I don't get
there how asta says at the end of every
episode not giving them up is my magic
and that's words to live by my friend
watch freak Li is better than what's
happening here we'll be in Punk'd boat
yes it is you're like you're okay you're
this conformist anti Shonen all right
monster okay
for the most part anime if why would you
call me all right guys I enjoy black
clover you [ __ ] bastard
the second they said I enjoy a little
bit everyone's like unsub unsub and I
got so appalled I don't understand you
used to be so anti Shonen and now you're
into black clover black Club way is
those shonan's using anymore that says
black clover is awesome I'm just saying
I'm enjoying watching it for now I don't
know I might get bored okay
it's [ __ ] scheduled Superman so
that's a good chance I enjoy example
super but I wouldn't be like make a
video state variable super is the
greatest anime I just enjoy watching
like sometimes you watch them just enjoy
I watch a bunch of lately I beginning
into the thing I'm watching classic 80s
action films with like Van Damme and you
know souls are so old and [ __ ] it's not
because they're they're just fun to
watch it's just like guys like manly and
what fun you know it also used to be fun
to watch Powerpuff Girls oh did you guys
know they like did did you guys know the
Powerpuff Girls had like a Dragonball Z
like how yeah Dragon Ball and drugged
Busey yeah Powerpuff Girls on Powerpuff
Girls Z did you guys know that I
appreciate it
Hunter hunter if you like my clover I
like I said I didn't hate hunter on
through it it's just that I wasn't
compelled to go beyond the first season
that was me looks to me you're just as
if you're forcing yourself to watch
black clover well then again I still
feel like Hunter hunter was really dead
inside for me and I apologize for that
just drop the damn series alright um
look I'm on it's not like I'm hating it
totally it's just
coming from the guy who's so anti you
know average Shonen well it depends what
it depends what like if you tell me that
you know whatever you know this generic
Shonen is the greatest anime of all time
whether it's my hero academia or
anything I I would say no you can enjoy
it and it's fun but it's definitely
can't compared to like Gurren Lagann or
you know my film Alchemist Brotherhood
like he can't compare to certain enemy
that doesn't mean you can't enjoy it but
I'm just saying like don't go overboard
and become a fanboy where this is the
best thing ever and if you insult it
I'll kill you like I am Gurren Lagann
don't be that guy like I am for si oh
yeah do not be that guy no I mean like I
said oh my word look I understand what
you're saying I get you it can't be the
greatest thing ever
but if you continue hunter hunter then
you'll see if you watch the Chimera ant
arc itself is like a miniseries and it's
like nothing you've seen it's totally
original in every way it's in fact it
takes a while to build up to the climax
just so the climax can be done so right
the whole climax takes place in two
minutes
and those two minutes are played in
basically slow motion over many episodes
okay from many different perspectives
I'm definitely going to continue hunter
hunter and I'm not even like arguing
with you about it I'm not I'm not hating
on it is just like it didn't what the
parts of it that I watched I wasn't like
wow this is amazing however however a
lot of these long-running anime Shonen
anime end up picking up later and you've
argued this as well knocks yeah we're
three I agree completely
my whole point is a lot a lot of people
now who are hating on black over in two
years my black man I love black over
after the anime picks up if it does my
not but if it does then that's payment
we're gonna have this theme online where
I was like yeah it's enjoyable and
you're such a [ __ ] trash man no no no
I mean I mean people know both to people
sticking with the series now what makes
you sing that in the check in two years
time but that depends who is our people
sticking with it or not we
no we know that there are people who are
hating on it but overall is the average
anime Muir sticking with it that's
something that's gonna be determined
after this first season and if we find
out if they even have like a second
season after or whatever that will that
be the confirmation basically no your
sarcastic entendre video yes I do
I liked it and you wrote on Twitter you
didn't even watch hunter hunter and you
still like my videos and that's how good
I am I mean that's a good prime example
right there with us a oh you know for
like comparing us AOS popularity and
with like clover a lot of people were
hating on that and it's a big meme and
the animated community Watership there's
actually a big fan service for it
well you misunderstand also in a way
because everyone loved Sao when it
started everyone loved it it was the
thing that everyone was talking about
the reason why there was such a backlash
is because people felt betrayed
well according to pedantic romantic the
reason there was a backlash was
exclusively because of did you bro no
it's it's because of fighting season two
that's why you know feminism I've also
gotten so many people asking me what is
the what is high school the Dead Season
2 when I told them so many times it
ain't gonna happen anytime soon it just
don't get your hopes up and anger that's
probably never gonna happen by the
highschool DxD season for rich what yeah
different stadium notes go
wait what school did just what III
internet yeah he's going to find the one
piece is going to no no no no wait no no
I've read in the manga but no that's
[ __ ] cuz like I said name one island
he went to specifically to find the one
piece every single island has old their
whole entire
he's on the boat
now he's there with a fork in every time
she's there with her luck right it will
put it to islands she'll go
that Island over there is safe that
Island over there is good let's go over
there but there's also gluttonous
messages that they had to follow her and
the whole entire thing is that he has to
go to every single Island and known his
presence in every place not only
actually closer than they were before
I mean exactly you're up-to-date I
assume yeah yeah yeah I'm on today yeah
you know about the the Pony glyph stuff
right yeah yeah of course they're there
around the world century the void
century is the most interesting part for
me Oh again with that
and raftel they have a place that
they're trying to get to right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I know I know what
you saying yeah but they're trying to
get to it now after how many [ __ ]
chapters was enjoyable like if you
follow Oda in his interviews he'll even
tell you like he gives you signs and
hints of how close you are to the one
piece and you don't even realize it or
the fact that it might be right under
your nose and you haven't realized it
you know a writer's trying to make
themselves oh yeah no no no by me when
he had the chance to get a hint to get
information where the one piece could be
when you saw boy up to Raley what did he
do yeah he turned it down he said it's
not fair whatever yeah I was gonna
bitch-slap him like [ __ ] one piece we
just learned him adventures Oh miss
Sunday and all that [ __ ] and then he was
that okay there's vivvy let's help baby
you know the game involved in that
ramanga you could take every single more
like story line and just say like you
can make it sound as bland and his death
as you're making it sound there's no
comparison Naruto you guys it's my show
okay this is what happens everyone
jumped on me when I was like I'm
enjoying black clover and now when your
one piece is getting attacked one piece
is shown in - ladies and gentlemen so
that's why you see when you when you get
hate then you get hey give K hey you get
hate back so there I was excited you
think you're so slick and it wasn't even
me it wasn't even me giving it back it
was someone else who was hating on me
earlier so point being karma just
happened live on this stream yes so it's
time guys
to wrap it up there you know we can all
agree that highschool DxD the entire
shakes episode so hand tie could have
covered entire high school DXP and done
it better that's why I keep calm and
watch hentai but whatever whatever you
want to do recon that's your thing um
before we go recon who are you what do
you do what up my boys is your boy recon
and I do them anime top ten lists yeah
that's about it
anime top ten lists and that's a quality
hentai review yeah quality hentai
reviews as well do check them out yeah I
do watch them live as well
disappointed when you finally know
something Lex I don't know I'm sorry
about that you're just telling me Happy
Thanksgiving
do you have any so happy Thanksgiving oh
yes I am now I gotta I do
animenews funny enemy skits and soon I'm
going to be getting into animations oh
[ __ ] nice nice link in the description
Knox Taku hello everybody
next a coup I do a Hana me analysis
sarcastic anime content parody satire
everything you could possibly want is
basically on my channel and i'm anti
hypocrisy if you're hypocrite I I'm just
gonna be upset and I'm gonna make a
sarcastic video about you and they'll be
sarcastic and it will be so sarcastic
you won't even realize it's about you
lend it to me for the record I put the
hip in hypocrite I said that yes I'm
waiting for applause but anyways moving
on Thank You nuts soul maka yep so soul
here so much yeah my channel is gonna be
focused mainly on manga it's been a
while since of hot video put on air
because I've just been mad busy with
work and stuff you know probably after
Christmas is when my channel is really
gonna pick up steam really feed bro yeah
you know exactly I know bills to be on
the way you never know you always catch
me now and then anyway on Animax discord
link is in the description
and if you want to get involved in this
after party the starting straight as
this video ends click on that link get
involved and I'll catch you in a general
voice chat yeah voice voice chat
afterparty
rank of a into this course right after
this looking forward to seeing you guys
there and yeah thank you for joining us
as always sequels are gonna be crazy
next year absolutely nuts absolutely
nuts
um thanks everyone on the panel for
joining me recon don't do it see the
space cowboy did you mean him a certain
mean channel mutant a pretty shirt was
still alive I know we are we are because
I decided everyone can judge recon live
this is nice yes let's go through us
again now I gotta what do you think of
recon
what's an [ __ ] hey gone anyway you
later bye